bonjour et bienvenue dans technal de tv
spéciale d'un grand champion de
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs avec jérôme
on fera ça lui jérôme salle et stephen
alors dans cet épisode des grands
champions on va voir un joueur qui a
défrayé la chronique dans les années 60
oui c'est gligoric le yougoslave
rigoriste et yougoslaves svetozar de son
prénom d'un grand joueur d'attac grand
joueur contre joueur d'attaquants
joueurs de tournois aussi il a remporté
de nombreux tournois quand il était au
faîte de sa de sa puissance notamment
shanghai cinq fois hastings il a gagné à
mar del plata manie alone farine aux
états unis mais il n'a jamais été en
mesure de discuter la couronne mondiale
bizarrement c'était plus un joueur de
tournoi 15 jours de match oui alors il
fait partie de cette école yougoslave
ans et que les yougoslaves avaient
d'ailleurs leur ouverture à elle a eu je
veux dire parce qu'il y avait mes
ouverture you cela il y avait un style
de jeu hugo cela avec et surtout weeds
et des joueurs qui cherchent l attaque
avant tout c'était vraiment des purs
attaquants
qui qui ont un peu initié ce mouvement
comme ça des échecs dynamique il
chercher ça c'était des joueurs qu'on
allait chercher le jeu les été très
joueurs et en plus en plus il était
porté par un public de fans parce que la
yougoslavie était le pays au monde où il
y avait la plus forte densité de joueurs
et où les spectateurs étaient les plus
férus de jeux d'échecs un nombreuses
anecdotes qui relate que notamment pour
le phisheur spassky de 72 belgrade avait
déjà été six autres van doos nom de 72
heures trente de la belgrade avait été
d'abord ciblé oui parce que ça convenait
afficheur de juin yougoslavie parce
qu'ils savaient que les gens étaient des
vrais fans des chats qui est pas ça ne
dérangeait pas de jouer du côté points
et des soviétiques même si les gosses à
vie était plus ou moins dépendants d'eux
dans la sphère des pays satellites de
l'union soviétique mais il savait qu'à
belgrade il aurait un public fervent way
qui aime l attaque
ouais donc c'était c'est un pays où les
échecs qui sont une vraie religion 1
était pas rare que dans les journaux
sportifs yougoslave il ya des partis qui
soit retranscrite et que les joueurs
fassent la une est d'ailleurs le le
conte du passage par les 92 le match
revin jeu fischer ce parce qu'il ya eu
20 ans plus tard a eu lieu à belgrade en
yougoslavie à l'insuline petite anecdote
sur la popularité des échecs en
yougoslavie
la légende raconte que lui bojovic un
autre grand joueur yougoslave
oui disputer un tournoi à mar del plata
donc il y avait un grand décalage
horaire avec la yougoslavie est
l'équivalent yougoslave du journal
l'équipe a décalé son horaire de sortie
pour pouvoir retranscrire la partie de
limoger beach donc au lieu de sortir à 8
heures du matin ils ont ils ont fait
paraître leurs numéros à 10 heures du
soir pour pouvoir avoir la partie de lui
roger michell à donner à leurs lecteurs
on imagine si l'équipe aujourd'hui
décalé ses sorties pour une partie de
maxime vachier lagrave
oui septième à krueger a précisé honda
c'est donc ça montre la ferveur qui
avait enlevé la vie autour du jeu
d'échecs à l'époque d'accord ligori qu
ils auraient dû mais il n'est alors il
n'est en danger dans un tout jeune pays
puisque né en 1923
cinq ans après la fin de la guerre et
cinq ans après l'éclatement de l'empiré
austro-hongrois donc qui n'est dans un
tout jeune royaume qui s'appelle le
royaume des croates slovènes et serbes
en fait c'est le nom officiel us la vie
au départ quand pierre premier en est le
premier souverain et gligoric né dans
une famille très pauvre devenu lé savent
très très pauvre il perd son père très
jeune aussi et il va découvrir les
échecs mais ce n'est pas sa seule
activité il est aussi très fort en thème
l'école il est très fort en sport aussi
est il se distingue notamment par des
performances sportives
il est même convié à la fête de son
école pour être mis en valeur en tout
cas pour recevoir pierre de belgas la
vie le jeune souverain qui a le même âge
que lui il fait partie de dés des jeunes
gens qui ont offert des performances
sportives devant le nouveau souverain et
il est tellement pauvres qu'ils se cache
un petit peu de pierre deux parce que
ces vêtements sont à moitié déchiré et
n'osent pas se montrer au roi qui a le
même âge que lui ouais et voilà il en
tire sûrement une volonté de s'élever
une rage de vaincre qui va qui va
conserver et notamment dansé dansé
victoire en tournoi d'accord
alors après comment il démarre sa
carrière démarre sa carrière d'abord je
n'ai pas précisé mais il y tellement
pauvres qu'ils se fabrique un jeu
d'échecs avec des des bouchons de
bouteilles de vin d'accord lui-même quoi
lui même il se sculpte les pièces avec
un plateau récupérer etc
et puis s'il se débrouille comme ça il
est rapidement repéré parce que il a il
a bien sûr des qualités mais il est né
en 1923 et quand la guerre éclate
mais au moment où il devrait exploser se
consacrer uniquement échec
et malheureusement la yougoslavie est
prise dans la seconde guerre mondiale
dès 1939 d'ailleurs la yougoslavie
n'existe plus tout à fait en tant que
tel puisqu'il ya une partie la partie
croître bana a obtenu sous la pression
du père d'être séparé de la yougoslavie
pour y créer un état fasciste qui est un
état satellite en fait du troisième
reich la yougoslavie et en partie
démembré pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale grigory che est enrôlé de fait
dans les partisans les résistants
yougoslave mais il est pas très très
fort au combat et finalement il a la
chance de tomber sur un capitaine qui
est féru des chèques etc il exempte de
combat jusqu'à la guerre pour jouer avec
lui pour jouer avec lui et puis le
laisse aller
et disputer quelques quelques petits
tournant donc gorrite je continue à
jouer ce qui lui permet dès 1950 d'avoir
le titre de maître international et dès
très rapidement après le titre de grand
maître international hélas à sa carrière
est lancée
il est très très jeune encore et il
poursuit en parallèle deux de carrière
on peut dire qu'il est aussi
organisateur de tournoi puisque avait
plus de tournois dans les os la vie de
l'époque donc ils organisent beaucoup de
tournois dans l'après guerre et il a
aussi une bonne plume donc il est il
fait aussi un petit peu de journalisme
c'est un homme assez complet et qui au
delà de ses victoires en tournois
ensuite tenu des rubriques dans des
revues des chèques et dans des dans des
journaux ce qui lui a permis de
continuer de journalisme tout en
continuant à s'intéresser aux échecs et
il a bataillé avec les plus grands de
ces années-là des années 60 50 60 70
c'est à dire les fisher l'état louis-ii
les a tous rencontrés notamment au cours
des olympiades ce qui l'a mené l'équipe
de yougoslavie aux olympiades à des
résultats que la yougoslavie n'avait
jamais eu jusque là je crois qu'ils ont
été sont dues être 2e ou 3e des
olympiades dans les années 60-70
notamment grâce à glee go reach qui a
emmené aussi cette génération dans
laquelle ensuite il ya eu du beau gilles
beach donc il a été un instigateur fort
de des échecs tu es là donc on va voir
quelques photos wii 2
ligue olic alors voici en moi c'est une
première l'homme à la moustache ici il
sans doute en train de regarder une
partie il a d'ailleurs bien son regard
oui c'est vraisemblable alors il était
connu aussi pour être assez élégant il
s'est peut-être en réaction à son enfant
c'est un petit peu pauvre il a ensuite
voulu s'élever aussi bien dans la
société que éventuellement le montrer
aussi montré qu'ils avaient atteint un
certain statut social
il a été connu pour être très élégant et
aussi est très très pacifique avec ses
adversaires il disait toujours moi je ne
joue pas contre des adversaires je joue
contre les pièces oui c'est le titre de
son autobiographie
donc on va voir une autre photo alors
ici on le voit il est à gauche c'est ça
la guette à gauche ce sont je crois que
c'est un tournoi au beurre au zen ou
peut-être les mêmes les olympiades
il joue contre lui dès que pac-man
d'acorn et oman la pendule mécanique
valenciennes pendant une mécanique de
l'époque on voit aussi que les parties
devaient être relativement lente parce
que je crois qu'on devine une pâtisserie
et puis une
une boisson chaude oui il était
nécessaire de se ravitailler
il ya là on voit alors il ya un trait au
milieu mais c'est pas un tracé d'une
corde et voilà c'est une corde parce que
souvent dans les grands tournois comme
sales et les grands joueurs sont
protégés un peu d du public parce que le
public peut s'approcher bien sûr mais
pour éviter qu'il soit trop près qu'ils
puissent éventuellement ce qui gêne trop
les joueurs on est des cordes quand même
pour éviter qu'ils s'approchent trop
près du jeu donc c'est des cordes qu'on
voit souvent que c'est une sorte de ring
en fait souvent dans les derniers grands
tournois comme ça lui les grands maîtres
sont isolés des autres joueurs par une
corde et qui fait différé qui fait un
peu protection et qui fait ressembler la
reine des premiers échiquiers à une
sorte d'arène de boxe alors ici une
troisième photo alors c'est pas grégory
thil sur cette photo alors qu'est ce que
c'est que cette photo alors cette photo
alors à gauche c'est un sculpteur
yougoslave assez célèbre à l'époque qui
s'appelait me kovic et qui est en train
de sculpter le buste de bobby fischer
qu'on a reconnu à droite
alors forcément dans ces années-là
l'ombre du fisher est omniprésente parce
qu'il faut quand même pas oublier que
fischer il n'est en 40
3-3 et donc à 15 ans et déjà grands
maîtres donc cesser les années gilgo
beach aussi donc c'est toujours
d'ailleurs qui ont bataillé et north et
ça fait partie de la même génération et
on peut pas parler d'échec d'un décès
époque 50 60 et 70
bien sûr en grand sans parler de fond
que ce fichier really traîne toujours
donc train de toujours alors là ce qui
est amusant c'est que le sculpteur n'a
pas tu n'auras pas terminés à la fin de
la séance de pose le buste et c'est
gligoric lui-même qui va l'apporter aux
états unis en personne bobby fischer
voilà tout c'est à l'histoire c'est
celle histoire c'est que ce buste a été
ramenée donc ça veut dire qu'ils étaient
amis oui il avait des relations amicales
et puis comme j'ai dit fisher aimait
beaucoup la yougoslavie les mails jouer
ils savaient que les gens étaient de
fervents joueurs et ils y étaient bien
reçus
il faut rappeler quand même que la
yougoslavie faisait partie du camp
soviétique mais avec un certain statut
d'indépendance par rapport à d'autres
pays satellites
c'était assez indépendants notamment du
fait que ce sont les partisans
yougoslaves qui ont libéré la
yougoslavie et pas l'armée rouge
ouais ce qui a permis à tito d'avoir une
assise après la seconde guerre mondiale
lui permettant peut-être pas de traiter
d'égal à égal avec staline mais en tout
cas de montrer une certaine indépendance
donc lui la yougoslavie a toujours eu un
statut et un petit peu particulier et ce
qui fait que fisher 600t sûrement aussi
assez bien puisque avait un petit peu
plus de liberté que dans les autres pays
de l'ex union soviétique les pays alliés
de l'union sur les voilà donc on va
revenir maintenant au sur le plateau
puisque on va passer à un autre parti du
jour
oui qui va être une partie 2-2 grigorij
alors ici jouer alors on va passer sur
cette partie très belle partie vous
allez voir
magnifique une partie d'attaqué une
partie tendue et c'est une partie qui a
lieu en 1969
donc c est en pleine forme à ce moment
là parce qu'il faut peut-être au sommet
de son art
oui on peut considérer qu'il est au
sommet de son art entre 1965 et 1975
oui au saumon d'annoncer ça en guinée on
est au coeur du coeur de sa carrière il
a été quand même je les bats rappelé là
quand même été 11 fois champion de
yougoslavie
oui il a aussi une très forte longévité
il a eu son premier titre de champion de
yougoslavie en 1947 et son dernier en 71
oui seulement ça oui ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup et là ils jouent alors
par n'est pas face à n'importe qui
puisque il joue avec les noirs face à
victor corse noah et leur buteur corse
ne lui est encore un peu jeune puisque
il va finir par arriver en finale du
championnat du monde en 78 donc neuf ans
plus tard et il jouera la finale face à
anatoly karpov et encore une nouvelle
finale en 81 à merano toujours face à
karpov donc encore jeune on est en plein
essor
c'est quand même un des joueurs qui
montent on est joueur dont on sent que
ça va devenir un très très grand du jeu
d'échecs
donc il est déjà très fort oui qui est
déjà très fort et qui est qu'un joueur
qui est assez tard venu aux échecs ou
l'a pas été grand maître à 15 ou 16 ans
il a été beaucoup plus tard et donc sa
maturation étaient plus lentes aussi on
est un excellent comme un faire un
formidable jeu mais excellent mais
formidable combattant et quand je dis
comme ça il y joue encore aujourd'hui en
2012 il est toujours actuelle est
toujours actif il a encore fait partie
de l'équipe suisse il fait partie de
l'équipe suisse et il ya eu un match
jeunes talents contre des légendes très
récemment à genève et corneille a encore
réussi à gagner des parties contre des
grands maîtres internationaux
oh et le petit gamin il vit les
mangetout crouzet le violon le violon on
appelle d'ailleurs en veut plus de 80
ans et un jour agilité absolument
exceptionnel pour un drama bien sûr d'un
grand champion c'est un morceau qu'on ne
peut pas ignorer
et donc ce grand champion en corse nole
qui rencontre le grand champion de la
journée celui de cette émission rigaud
reach et vous allez voir c'est parti
avec le coup des quatre caves f6 de la
part de greenwich c4 et on rentre avec
g6 ça y est dans une ouverture de type
indien on veut jouer fou g7
on peut encore rejoindre une feld avec
des seins qu'on va voir ça va être le
coup suivant qui a laissé 3 et salifou
g7 alors après fou g7
on est dans une ouverture est ndianor
pourquoi est ce parce que le fou est
développé à l'est contrairement à
l'ouest de vienne où on joue le 6 et
vous mes quatre ans mais le fou à
l'ouest alors c'est l'inversé puisque on
a les noirs c'est en général on voit la
partie du côté blanc mais vu qu'on
regarde et que les corric aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas ne pas regarder du côté noir
donc ici on a mis fous chez set et après
eux 4 qui est le coût normal puisque les
noirs n'ont pas empêché la pousse ces
centrales c'est à dire que on est dans
le jeu hyper modernes ici c'est à dire
que on n'empêche pas les menaces
positionnelle entre guillemets ici
d'occupation massive du centre de la
part des blancs mais on contre attaque
dont contrôle à distance à distance
c'est à dire qu'on va contre-attaquer se
sentir on va jouer des six plus tard et
puis on va contre attaquer on va jouer
une scène qu'on va jouer ces 5
en fait on laisse les blancs occuper le
centre bien sûr ça leur donne plus d
espace mai mais ce sont c'est aussi une
cible
et oui parce qu'avoir un centre aussi
puissant c'est aussi une responsabilité
puisqu'il faut le il faut le défendre
il faut défendre exactement et
c'est une conception qui est née dès les
années trente même allé clean laisser
quelques fois les joueurs avant ces
trois pions voire quatre pions dans
certaines parties pour justement miner
ce centre notamment avec des pions du
côté des pions ses pions f pour mettre à
mal ce centre en puisque à voir se
constituer ce centre nécessite aussi de
le défendre
voilà deux le défend le maire donne côté
si on le contre attaque pas de façon
virulente on va se faire étouffer voilà
c'est ici à double tranchant c'est à
double tranchant il faut donc faire très
attention donc des six typique lors des
six est fait pour tout de suite contenir
les éventuelles velléités de pousser si
en plus on va affaiblir ses pions là par
contre 1 et puis on prend qui comprend
en échange les dames avec échec et puis
après on a des soucis de de faiblesse on
peut jouer après calais gicquel qui
menace l 2 et le pion mais 5 est perdu
donc ça peut aller très vite il faut
éviter de faire n'importe quoi et les
blancs ici faut pas se précipiter
donc il faut continuer à se développer
tranquillement avec cavaliers en f3 on
développe pour regarder les cavaliers
avant les fous on sort on prépare foule
de on prépare le petit rock et on
s'occupera plus tard des manoeuvres à
adopter en fonction du jeu des noirs
donc petit rock foule 2
et là tout de suite ça y est contre
attaque alors c'est classique
alors on se dirait que on pourrait se
dire pardon que les blancs pourraient
prendre 1 5 mai après prise prises et
cavale et prend en fait on peut échanger
les dames
et puis les noirs pourrait par exemple
se venger sur le pion à eux quatre
puisque après calais prend et bien le
fou prendre un cavalier donc c'est très
dangereux pour les blancs
d'imaginer qu'on gagne ou qu omission ne
gagne pas et surtout on prend du plomb à
prendre on prend du temps pardon à
prendre un bio pendant que les noirs ont
violemment contre-attaqué derrière je
vous assure que c'est pas une bonne une
bonne idée on va pas entraîner subtilité
d'ouverture ici c'est pas le but mais
petit rock ici qu'avait laissé 6 alors
maintenant on peut même plus prendre
vraiment véritablement le club puisqu'il
est protégée alors le côté un peu
provocateur de ce coup parce qu'on
n'invite quasiment les blancs oui à
venir harceler le cavalier en jouant
dans le cou qui semblent naturelles des
5 mai c'est le coût que fait
effectivement contenant effectivement là
on menace avec les noirs d'aller faire
des échanges au centre et de mettre la
dame sur une position nous les aires
vis-à-vis du fou ce qui est toujours
désagréable donc la tentation est forte
de jouer le coup suivant des cinq ce que
corps je fais et les noirs ont
volontairement poussé les blancs de
saint pascal y ait plus de tensions ici
donc ça veut dire que maintenant ce pion
au sein qui est extrêmement solide on a
donc une phalange de pions ici solide et
tout de suite comme les phalanges de
pions soit une brique et elles sont
stables et comme elles sont stables on
peut déjà regardé vers où on regarde
alors aeio regardez ici en regarde vers
là c'est à dire qu'ici avec cette
construction ici cette phalange pions
vise les lois donc notamment là on à la
case f4 pourquoi pas mettre en cavale et
h5 caraïbes 4 on peut aussi attaquer la
base ici de cette chaîne de pion par le
fameux coup f5 classique de cette
opposition faudra d'abord bouche il
kadhafistes mais comme on a verrouillé
le centre le centre est stable et comme
le centre est stable on peut attaquer
sur les ailes a contrario les blancs eux
ont une phalange de pions ici qu'ils
regardent de ce côté là donc on va
attaquer allèles dame sur la base de la
chaîne adverse c'est à dire ceux puis on
est 6 voir ce qu on sait c est avec des
plans
à base de baies 4 c 5 mois la b4 csn
coup même semblait quand on perd aussi
et c'est l'idée c'est d'ouvrir le jeu de
ce côté là avec les tours et d'envahir
le côté dames
donc voilà le théâtre de la partie et un
peu quand pc un peu les grandes idées de
cette ouverture
c'est une ouverture qui bloque le sens
mais qui invite chacun des camps a
attaqué du côté opposé
donc c'est toujours les parties souvent
violente celle où on attaque des côtés
opposés
c'est vrai dans les parties sicilienne
avec un petit roquet en europe mais
aussi dans les parties fermés ou en off
du même côté parce que quand le centre
est fermé on peut plus facilement
envisager de pousser les pions de son
propre camp de son propre droit
notamment
on n'a pas trop peur puisque le centre
empêche finalement des attaques de
déstabilisation centrale justement on
peut passer on ne peut pas attaquer au
centre très difficile donc cavalier
hausse est donc tout de suite on a un
cavalier en hausse est à noter que ce
chaos les bains déjà peut contrôler
cette quasi si ces tirs aide à la
poussée f5 peut aider un peu la
poussière scène parfois c'est une
cavalière on va aussi parfois jouer
rouages suite on va le mettre en g8 et
il va aider à ce que le fouillent années
ici sur cette case parce que ce fou il
est souvent puissants en à l'estonienne
parce que tôt ou tard on arrive à faire
des échanges
sans trop se mouiller on saute mais 6e
puis on saute pas il est bouché parfois
on le fait vivre
en passant par la justice ça arrive
aussi on n'en est pas là car ils étaient
deux donc là il est des deux alors
l'idée de cavaliers des deux est simple
c'est que en jouant ce coup et bien déjà
avec ses contrôles et casgrain ça c'est
que ça peut être bien mais surtout
contre leucate surprotège la case aux
quatre ça veut dire que tôt ou tard karl
et noir joueront f5
on n'a pas peur on peut reprendre et
aussi ce cavalier aidé par la poussée
bécade peut venir en b3 pour appuyer une
poussée c4 c5 c4 csn on prend des six
on met la tour en c1 on envahit ces sept
et on en grappe tous les pions c'est ça
c'est le plan c c'est le plan c'est
l'idée de toute façon les blancs on va
le voir vont jouer à l'ailé à elle d'un
voile a donc après qu'elle ait des deux
les noirs ici ajouté aller 17
il prépare tout simplement la poussette
5 alors on prépare il ya deux idées avec
les 17 ont préparé le 5 mais aussi en un
petit oeil sur ces 5 c'est à dire
qu'aulas pour les blancs c'est difficile
de pousser ses scènes tout de suite
alors ça constitue cette classe c 5 1
avant postes pour le cavalier il a un
seul défaut cet avant poste c'est qu'il
ya encore un pion qui peut chasser le
cavalier alors oui alors c'est ça peut
parfois dans certaines ouvertures et
stinson avant postes mais disons que là
effectué avec la travaille à b4 mais
c'est surtout qu'ils courent ils
empêchent ces 5 et l'emploi comme ça
mais on évitera d'y aller parce qu'on va
se faire chasser avec gain de temps mais
parfois d'un certaine ouverture cnn on
peut le jouer en attaquant le 4 et après
il faut le consolider par le cou à 5
mais là c'est pas le cas là ce n'est pas
le cas il est plutôt ici il contrôle et
se retrouve bon business capoue csm
peut-être souvent même ils reviennent
tout de suite après pour continuer la
pression sur eux quatre ils restent pas
longtemps ici d'autant qu'ici bouche un
peu l'avenir du fou s'est vite mais en
attendant il un petit oeil là-dessus et
ça ça empêche les idées de ses cinq
immédiate un mais quatre lors des 4
pourquoi pas mais c'est 5 reste
impossible qu'ils ont pu et on prend
donc on a gagné un pion ça va pas ça
empêche au moins deux cavaliers de
s'installer
voilà en ce sens alors une idée des fois
pour les noirs ici si tu joues à 5
l'idée d' à 5 c'est que les blancs ne
peuvent pas jouer à trois pour on veut
garder le pion ici pour garder la
pression ici bien sûr on peut pas jouer
à trois puisque prise prise et la tour
ici prend la tour donc ça va pas on peut
pas protéger des pions et en cas de
prise des blancs en a cinq
si on prend 1,5 le problème c'est qu'on
ne contrôle plus ses 5 à la maintenance
est un véritable avant postes à wall e
camerling oui maintenant on peut
envisager effectivement de manière assez
simple puisque là y'a plus rien pour les
blancs alors le problème c'est qu'après
ça comment les blancs pour attaquer là
c'est pas simple à 6,1 calais en plus
qu'il ya là alors souvent les blancs ici
vous dans ce cas là le kung fu à trois
avec l'idée qu'en cas de prise prises
c'est le fou qui joue le rôle d'
attaques de le casser 5 donc en
conjonction avec une cale et mettront
pourra jouer c'est simple quand même et
on a aussi en cas de b6 la possibilité
de jouer à 4 à 5 bon c'est pas l'idée de
la partie ici qui s'est joué puisque
lloris a choisi de ne pas jouer ce genre
de coups souvent d'ailleurs l'idée de
décès de freiner la tacc ne fait qu'à
renforcer
ça peut arriver voilà ça peut arriver
c'était quand même en faisant cette
opération on ouvre la colombe et ça peut
donner des idées supplémentaires aux
blancs donc il s'occupe pas de ça des os
x qui joue f5
voilà ça y est jouable cinq considèrent
que l'heure est venue de jouer ce coup
de libération voilà toute attaque
surtout coups d'attaqué de libération on
voit que alayli dame qui a des
manoeuvres mais il se dit qu'il vaut
mieux essayer d'aller plus vite de son
côté voire d'essayer de restreindre les
normes à neuf de son adversaire c'est
exactement si un jeu est effectivement
de
d'attac deux côtés opposés pendant que
l'adversaire attaque il faut être essayé
d'attaquer plus vite de l'autre côté
nous on a un droit à viser si on arrive
à faire maths mais tant pis si on perd
une pièce à côté donc les blancs doivent
faire attention il suffit pas à
l'attaquer ici parce que là bas c'est
plus grave
il ya quand même un endroit derrière
même si c'est là ont remixé lent parce
que les pions sont de loin du d'attaquer
le roi alors à noter aussi que souvent
les noirs un plan d'attaqué base de f4
et puis on pousse les autres pions mais
ça ne marche que si les puits les blancs
ont poussé le pion à f3 ce qui arrive
des fois pour protéger le 4 mai oui
c'est important parce que les noirs ont
besoin d'une cible dans la chaîne de
pions blanche et s'ils purent f3 n'ai
pas poussé il n'y a pas de signe apathie
et certains imaginant les plus brefs 4
et 10 4 et après il ya toujours pas de
possibilité de briser
à noter que d'ailleurs avec cette
batterie fou dames c'est dur de pousser
g4 il va falloir le préparer ça va être
long donc
pour l'instant le coup et cinq efforts
mais il faut garder l'attention
4 tant que ce coup f3 n'a pas été joué
et il faut donc essayer de l'augmenter
et par exemple par qualif 6 on va
revenir un f6 alors on y va
cavalli b3 donc la bombe est logique
qu'elle aimait 3 on augmente la pression
sur ces cinq voix là et on a gardé le
flou en c1 pour avoir une petite oeil
sur ce côté là mais pourquoi pas on
aurait pu envisager de l'as de laisser
le cavalier aussi en d2 et de jouer le
couffo à 3 une fois 3 qui protège aussi
la taxe est simple par transparence
prise prise et le fou contrôler ses
cinquièmes et la belgique en rich ne
traîne pas il ne joue pas le coup câble
et f6 qui envisageait il prend tout de
suite en leucate voilà il ne traîne pas
alors les noirs parfois attendre avant
de prendre 4 c'est irresponsable de
prendre dans le 4 puisque on peut on
peut craindre du côté noir quand même
ouf ou g5 montant qu'il fut le cavalier
en d2 c'est vraiment peu ils vont
tellement prendre un train neuf ou gsm
est fou g5 se heurterait peut-être
acheter son envie de pousser les pions
de toute façon donc c'est pas forcément
extrêmement gênant pour les pour les
noirs de l'oeuf ou gsm de deux d'avoir
des la possibilité de pousser les pions
pour chasser le fou s'il prend 1,7 dont
on a donné comme un fou face à un
cavalier et puis bon on a des pions
noirs qui peuvent continuer à avancer
donc
bon mais c'est un thème on peut
l'envisager alors elle fera en quatre
quarts les 3,4 alors voilà alors les
blancs ont intérêt maintenant à garder
ils ont mille cavaliers ici ils peuvent
une autre fois il est venu ici alors ici
une intervention les blancs intérêt à
garder une pièce ici pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un fou l'atide hors cour avec
une tournée arrière et se fout son seul
désir moyen long terme c'est de pousser
eux quatre pour se libérer pour
augmenter son rayon d'action
donc les blancs est d'ailleurs un tout
intérêt dans ce type de parti a
verrouillé la classe de 4 c'est pas
toujours facile parce que les noirs
peuvent augmenter la pression par calais
six parfois f5 et la case de 4 est sous
pression
c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait que les
gorilles tout de suite exactement comme
si samba le fer tant qu'il est chaud et
on essaye de se débarrasser de ce
cavalier e 4 et surtout de libérer la
cad rica pour la populaire et la caisse
alors là pas évident qu est ce qu on
fait alors si on joue aux dés coups
comme ça c'est possible mais on a moins
de contrôle de la case des cats
assène-t-elle à 15,4 aussi parce que
regarder
très vite on peut envisager des cas
légers 4 c'est ce qu'a ramené ce
cavalier et devient un f5 pourquoi pas
et des dommages 4 av
des attaques donc on a quand même envie
d'avoir l'oeil le plus longtemps
possible sur cette case
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait alors si aux
jouets 3 c'est possible merci on joue f3
on affaiblit un peu les cases noires ça
peut être un thème et puis on a donné un
point ici pourquoi pas
ici deux
d'actions ou simplement encore noir
peuvent prendre 1 4 et après la prise
ici et bien c'est pas forcément c'est
pas forcément le mieux pour les pour les
blancs non plus puisque eux mêmes non
plus la mobilité qu'ils avaient eu
quatre puisque la séance est bloqué bon
ceci dit
pour les pour les noirs c'est le fou là
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de mal à oui c'est
ça cesse donc tout de suite s'est passé
pas très bon voilà donc ici c'est pour
ça que parfois c'est pour ça que c'était
pas forcément bien d'être caméra parce
qu'on a envie d'avoir les deux cavaliers
finalement qui se remplacent les
cavaliers sont meilleurs bloqueurs que
les fous voilà toute façon donc ici en
quatre dans l'idéal il vaut mieux qu'ils
aient un cavalier qu'un fou oui c'est la
meilleure pièce a posté devant le pion
adverse
une autre idée celle où dame ces deux
messieurs vous donner c'est de cavale et
prendra me prend effet au f5 avec gaines
de danse on le fout on attaque la dame
donc c'est pas que les airs la de savoir
quoi faire sur food et 3 way c'est
possible food et 3 mai alors sur food et
3 n'empêche pas cavalier 5 aprilia
carrier des quatre ici le fou empêche la
dame de contrôler la case des quatre il
ya aussi ça c'est con à la casse des
quatre faut pas oublier qu'elle est
contrôlée par transparence par le fou
c'est aussi une classe central faible et
donc un point d'appui pour les noirs bon
voilà qu'à l'été trois considérations
générales kg droit et maintenant qu'elle
essayait seller donc allée f 5
on vise la casse des quatre ans vise la
casse des quatre ans vise aussi de jouer
eux quatre peut-être un peu plus tard
avec le fou qui se réveille
ici on à tour donc on voit que les cases
noires du centre sont affaiblis et le
coût 45 augmente la pression cavaliers
pros 25
il a compris comment il élimine ce
cavalier qui met pression sur le centre
quant à l'épreuve c'est gai là il ya
deux prises possibles allant dans son
livre les 60 meilleures parties souvent
pichardie qu'il faut prendre dont deux
avec le pion j'ai mes soucis le fait
jamais alors il nous dit dans l'analyse
mais il ne fait pas dans la partie c'est
de prendre du plomb j'ai ça peut
paraître étrange de débarrasser son rock
de priver son rock d'un bouclier
oui c'est vrai et mais en fait on ramène
un pion vers le centre on contrôle la
case aux quatre et on a la colonne j'ai
ouverte et on ouvre la colonne j'ai ça
peut être un thème aussi puisqu'on peut
jouer tours fc est et après fouet suite
par exemple pour protéger des 6 et
protéger ses 50 espérances on peut même
la loi on peut mettre ça tours angers 7
et attaquer le rock on a deux pions
aussi au racing g5 qui peuvent s'avérer
mobile voit l'armée ya des contres pour
les blancs puisque on peut jouer avec 4
s4 qui empêche la mobilité des pions et
qui pose une question et puis on
centrale s'il pousse bien on a plus de
casse des 4 on va être obligés d'émettre
en cavalier on pourra enfin les blancs
pourront lui mettre un cavalier ils
pourront avec le four b2 avoir une belle
diagonale au side attaque donc tous à
s'estimer c'est pas clair de savoir s'il
vaut mieux prendre du plomb du fou donc
il choisit de prendre du fou ça se
faisait pas mal donc l'avantagent de la
prise du fou c'est que l'on sûr qu'on se
protège la case de 4 donc on va pouvoir
jouer e400 craindre trop d'être d'être
pris au monde voulu et ça va libérer la
puissance du fou donc là les noirs on le
fout j'essaie être potentiellement libre
puisqu'on peut jouer 4 à tout moment il
n'est plus enfermé derrière ses propres
pions voilà maintenant pour attaquer le
roc blanc c'est moins clair aussi parce
qu'on a plus de pions en attaque
extrêmement fort faut 3 donc fou et 3 on
développe le fou on contrôle un cas ces
cintres une fois de plus mais la poussée
devient de plus en plus possible ils ont
d'actualité le seul petit problème des
blancs ici c'est qu'ils semblent avoir
un petit peu de retard dans leur dans
leurs plans que ce qu'on a dit qu'il
n'avait inquiète et quel est le roi
l'autre avec dame quand je peux hier n'a
pas encore poussé ses 5 alors que will
go reach déjà poussé f5
c'est vrai qu'il a il a encore il a
quand même l'initiative initiative mais
il n'y a pas de marée de pions en route
en fait disons c'est à dire voilà le
problème c'est que là pour l'instant on
ne voit pas trop où les pions pour
attaquer il n'y a pas eu
d'affaiblissement cochon n'a pas faibli
son camp pollution est encore équilibré
h5 alors voilà on y va c'est à dire
qu'ici maintenant h5 ben on veut essayer
d'attaquer quand même un peu donc on
prend de l'espace ont joué à cinq alors
h5 va permettre permet aux cavaliers g4
ou une fougue et 4 pour échanger les
fous et ensuite attaqué ce fou 3 6 ans
guette les noirs on peut effectivement
envisager
qu'avais-je et 4 qui posent la question
foudroie où elles font exactement tout à
fait on consolide la case g4 d'ailleurs
cochonnailles joue maintenant s3c y est
alors le premier froid quand on a joué à
cinq c'est que on n'attaque plus le pion
h5 avec free dame donc on peut envisager
pas tout de suite parce que là le fou et
3 contre la cage hussein ont peu réagi
plus tard de jouer gsm g4 qui est
typique de l'estonienne pour ouvrir le
jeu notamment sur la colonne d'air
en jouant les cartes on peut envisager
après des prises ici ou parfois même de
jouer j'ai trois c'est à dire qu'il ya
des possibilités de tactique après de
pouzauges et 3 qui affaiblit le roc
blanc et qui peut s'avérer extrêmement
dangereux avec une attaque de maths
bon on n'en est pas là mais ça donne
c'est le stand inscrit ses responsables
locaux f3 à une bouche le flou 77 se
contrôler mais alors l'intérêt des
froids aussi c'est que on a un oeil sur
quatre voilà mais ça peut être aussi
sait on peut pousser le théâtre avec un
échange sa échangerait ce pion
potentiellement faible enjeu 1,4 en juin
car on est déconnecté des autres pions
puisque nous payons des six ne peut pas
venir l'aider bon élan on peut les
changer ça peut libérer totalement le
jeu noir l'âme 17 ans dames 17
l'idée donne des sept allers simples
connecter les tours et notamment venir
808 on va aider à la poussée de 4 les
noirs l'abattage au centre c'est à dire
que l'alta que sur l'ale dame
n'a pas encore eu lieu et le centre non
plus n'a pas il n'a pas vraiment réussi
à bloquer le centre gauche mais il n'a
pas fait en tout cas il n'a pas fait du
tout dam des deux donc la corse ne lui
aussi lycée tour très important et puis
bon ben là il ça rend le coût gsm g4
difficile parce que la meinau pour
protéger la cage et 5 même car il ne
suffit pas faudrait jouer le fou et 6 et
puis c'est long c'est long pour essayer
de protéger g5 et de pousser donc dam
des deux hommes bons coups très
clairement des six alors un coup logique
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu c'est à dire
b6 augmente et le conditionnement le
contrôle noir sur ces scènes en cas de
ces cinq d'ailleurs à noter que tu
comprends et le pion des cinq attention
peut être en prise à leur attention
parce qu'il ya quand même le roi ici il
ya des cloisons possible mais ça reste
une possibilité à 4 alors là c'est
classique maintenant aussi on a joué b6
en jouant b6 on donne la possibilité aux
blancs d'attaquer la chaîne de pion à
chaque fois que vous poussez un pion
c'est aussi l'offre d'une cible
l'adversaire donc c'est toujours
responsable un joueur hyper v hyper
moderne des années 30 disait que e4 le
premier coup blanc était déjà suicidaire
oui parce que c'était la fin des blancs
il avait déjà poussé un pion qu'ils
étaient déjà en danger mais c'est vrai
donc tu auras vite donc maintenant bon
blé noir se disent baisse et moi c'est
pas mon camp ici c'est plutôt regarder
un c'est plutôt les blancs qui sont en
possibilités d'attaquer là donc moi je
ne peux pas rester en défense
je vais là où je suis fort et aussi que
je suis fort au centre et sur les droits
alors on voit se dessiner la poussée 4
oui on voit se dessiner à pousser au cas
regardez comme elle est bien préparée
avant d'avoir lieu ils se pressent pas
pour le faire maintenant ses taux au
blanc de jouer donc logique et brassens
alors quelle est l'idée dassin cali
simple mais sûre maintenant on profite
du fait que l'une orange web et 6 pour
pouvoir prendre en b6 et faire une
évasion
parce que si on arrive à mettre la tour
ici en septième on voit tout de suite
que c'est très embêtant c'est toujours
embêtant de toute façon la dame et en
vis-à-vis donc on pourra pas reprendre
du pillon c
messi sur un ring on a même un sacrifice
de sacrifice de foin b6 puisqu'il y aura
le pion ses 7 qui sera cloué exact on
pourra menacer tout de suite vous
prendrez avec une possibilité de
reprendre à cause de tout programme donc
d'où l'idée d'en bailleurs de ce côté là
donc c'est l'heure pour rigaud reach à
son tour vu que les blancs sont en
contact à l'el dan de faire le son
propre contact à la fois aller le roi
parce qu'on touche le piouf 3 est au
centre puisqu'on a préparé la poussée de
quatre cas pas pu être contenir par
contre n'ont rien n'a pas à trouver les
moyens d'empêcher cette poussée c'est ce
que je disais souvent les blancs essaie
d'éviter d'enlever leurs pièces de
leucate pour éviter cette poussée qui si
on va plus regarder c'est ce fou il va
falloir faire attention dès que le
cavalier bouge et bien la tour est perdu
et ça serait une qualité et une qualité
c'est grave surtout une position comme
ça qui va se simplifier arvier dans une
finale avec une qualité de moins c'est
pas bon donc comprend b6 et la regarder
ou intermédiaire puis on prend 9 3
d'abord c'est à dire que là on laisse
pas aux blancs ici là on laisse pas on
ne prend pas le temps de reprendre ici
on prendre tout de suite là on menace de
prendre le fou eu deux donc c'est pas le
moment amélie blanc de faire de jouer de
jouer les rôles 1 pour envisager quoi
que l'on peut envisager provenance à
s'infléchir le regarde et on y réfléchit
un tour prend à 7 c'est tout à fait
possible imaginons que les blancs en
face pour prendre un set c'est
envisageable pourquoi pas l'air très
très bon mais qui on prend 1,2 alors le
problème c'est avec d'entre eux n'a pas
envie parce que la dame serait cloué sur
la tour cercle fou il a et on pourrait
tout simplement car les g4 et il
semblerait que le fonds soit perdue donc
quasi perdu mais sur dame de on peut
jouer tout re 1 et puis
les blancs garde une menace ici sur le
pion c7
donc si par exemple on joue un coup
comme ici on peut envisager kg quatre
attaques le fougueux 3 pourquoi pas
c'est pas mal ça va quand même la tour
français 7 en attendant mon tour penser
alors 1 et en trois sets et simplement
on peut prendre mais ça fait que ça fait
beaucoup de matériel puisqu'on prend le
fouet si tout reprend ça fait fou prend
et on regarde et même deux tours pour la
dame et on a trois pièces contre touré
fou avec une position forte hausse et
c'est jouable
c'est jouable sur ces quatre reprises ce
sera ça sera difficile pour les blancs
comme moi c'est jouable surtout pour les
noirs ils sont extrêmement actifs avec
la menace surtout que tour la tour e 1
peut pas prendre le pion de maïs de
touré fin match aurait fait math
attention est là il ya des grosses
grosses menaces en f1 donc c'est très
dangereux quand même pour les blancs de
faire ça donc après après un v6 peut
prendre froid mais s'il vient de
regarder un peu pour voir ses
possibilités fou prend f3 et maintenant
ça y est je reprends tranquillement à
prendre est donc logique
on y voit c'est à dire ça y est la
pénétration voyez l'idée c'est que la
dame est attaqué en transparence c'est à
dire que la menace blanche c'est de
faire fou prendre b6 très important on
peut pas reprendre à cause de tout
programme
alors si on perd un pion des six
voiliers que la mariée depuis en blanche
devient forte
donc il faut faire quand même attention
donc il va falloir créer des contrôles
menace suffisamment forte pour
contrebalancer cette pression et c'est
ce que fait ou hybrides avec le joli
cavaliers au 444 c'est bien ça attaque
au centre
la dame est attaqué sa centralise à
noter que ça libère aussi le potentiel
il faut g7 donc dames c'est un bon
logique de la part de couronnes pourquoi
pas il veut pas donner son fou pourquoi
il veut pas donner son fou parce qu'il
est en s'y prend eh bien
ils affaiblissent en europe puisqu'il a
plu deux défenseurs des cases blanches
on peut envisager tout reprendre avec
pourquoi pas un doublement des tours
plus tard on peut envisager pourquoi pas
fou prend aussi et puis on commence à
faire pression sur les causes blanche
suivies d'oedèmes g4 éventuellement
suivie d'un objectif très fectivement
nous faut faire attention mais on
n'empêche pas attention il ya aussi il
ya cette menace qui est toujours la
fouge et quatre de la part d'aig aux
riches qui se lance à fond dans la
bataille rouge et 4 il veut essayer
d'éliminer ce défenseur du rock parce
que l'idée bingo rixe et l'attaqué le
roi parce que de toutes façons de ce
côté là il va perdre du matériel à cause
de cette tour qui est extrêmement bien
placé fou prend g4 de la part de
cornouaille et dans prend alors ça c'est
bien d'emprunt voilà on lâche par contre
le pion c'est cette sas et ça c'est le
danger bien sûr d'en prendre
créer un peu de pression bien sûr de la
pression sur le roi mais on voit pas
tout de suite comment on peut profiter
de ça même s'il ya du jeu bien sûr alors
attention le fou et 3 est presque en
l'air avec la tour derrière mais il faut
que la dame en reste à la défense se
foutent actifs
donc il ya des possibilités tactiques
pour les noirs alors notamment des coups
comme ici au regard des cavaliers c3 et
pouf échec au roi fourchette royal donc
tour princesse est de corse naked ibeku
tatouage est quand même pris un pion
était vrai donc il faut avec heliowatt
une telle en continu sur la taxe alors
c'est typique de l'estagnol
oui c'est à dire que la maintenance et
mat ou meurs il faut que les noirs
prouve eux et il faut que les noirs
prouvent que leur attaque est forte ça
semble quoi sans quoi c'est foutu parce
que là ils viennent de perdre un pion
essentiel le deuxième pion ici est perdu
et après la marée pur l'emportent
ne sera perdu voilà donc la sema tout
meurt ou à la limite échec perpétuelle
parfois ces gens de parti qui fait mal
léché perpétuelle c'est à dire un échec
auquel on ne peut pas se soustraire
et il ya ce cas là c'est parti alors il
faut faire attention aussi pour les
noirs à une menace très concrète c'est
tout reprend g7 est effectivement nous
avons bien vu tour projet cet échec
reprend et ensuite vous le shaq fu et
échecs et la tour est prise ils ont fait
un échange généralisé avec la tour f1 à
la fin ça fait égalité en échange mais
il ya plus de pièces pour attaquer et
qu'on la dise etc les blancs qui ont le
matériel en plus on a plus plus on va
échanger de pièces et plus cette
majorité blanche celle d'un homme va
peser lourd dans le résultat final
oui s'il y avait plus que le roi le
penplus diagne est donc maintenant il ya
pièces plus l'avantagé d'un pion est
criant mais on n'en est pas là et
illégaux rich a une vraie attaque c'est
à dire qu'après fou aux 5
il ya une pression qui augmente
terriblement regarder ça y est il ya
commencé à voir ici il commençait à y
avoir ici des possibilités d'attaqué
peut-être même demain
regardez par exemple vous prend h2 roi
prend d'un échec
roy g3 et cavale et g3 et comment on
empêche dans ma chouette parce que la
colonne est fait contrôler par les noirs
même si on fait un échange de tours
c'est une tour qui reprend et on voit
mal comment les noirs peuvent éviter le
match en match et donc une menace de
sacrifices en hd et là elle existe et ça
craint
c'est alors la défense de cornouaille et
très subtil
alors donne un nom fondée 4 pendant des
cats et après-demain des quatre coups
des quatre donc tous des quatre l'idée
de cornouaille est simple si tu prends h
2 on va prendre dans mes chèques
roger sur calais g3 attention avec le
fougeux contre le g7 laissez moi qui
fait échec
je suis obligé de venir en h1 et j'ai ce
qu'on appelle le fameux échec à la
découverte on va faire la variante à
l'entrée imaginons fou prend heine
pourquoi pas regarder dans ce cas-là roi
prend h 2 imaginons un coup comme le
dame h4 échec revient et avec l'idée
qu'à venise et rock avec g3 l'air très
fort puisque je menace mat le roi noir
ne le roi blanc par ne peut pas fuir un
f2 à cause de la tour et en plus je
menace aussi dame eux kallio deux échecs
au roi est prise de la dame mais c'est
au besoin de jouer au regard des poufs
échec
c'est plus que je sais qu'elle a
découverte en fait c'est matt puisque
ici regardez le fou contrôler la tour
donc je n'ai pas le choix mais le moi je
ne peux pas prendre la tour il ya aucune
pièce qui peut prendre la tour je suis
obligé de venir à cheville et d'un match
6 et 6 il ya aussi d'un machisme plaph
échec et mat terrifiés ces mots et
matoukou avant donc ça marche pas et oui
il faut être précis donc vous des cas
très fort donc meglio rich a tout vu
donc en fait vous des 4es a l'air fort
mais regardez mais il ya un petit
coureur de dire celle échanges détour
tout récent échec alors là peut-être
l'intérêt de tours et son échec c'est
que déjà à bombay en cas d'échec comme
on l'a vu tout à l'heure on peut venir
là maintenant et non plus à lire la
suite
et là que font les que font les blancs
sirois prend on va s'exposer un échec le
long de la colonne f alors si
ici roi prend un fort il faut qu'on le
regarde mais il faut qu'on regarde si
roy prend f1 on peut réagir oui c'est
encore mieux que ne vous croit on peut
imaginer proches de ceux proches deux
échecs nous faut prendre d'autres pas
d'échec me rendais on empêche le roi de
revenir donc ce qui fait que la ancrer
la menace touré fins minimath cavaliers
g3 matt la kabylie j'ai trois échecs
pardon on peut menacer aussi cavale et
j'ai trois échecs roi f2 et dames de
maths
donc il ya une menace de maths et si les
blancs jouent tour g7 il faut le faire
on peut jouer en fuite donc apple a pas
d'autres menaces pour les blancs là que
font les blancs et la menace ici par
contre reste on menace câble et j'ai
trois échecs
la tour empêche le roi de venir en
souvenir un réno et seimat donc que font
les noirs que font les blancs il ya
votre coin essayons d'imaginer un coup
comme
dames 3 par exemple il suffit de faire
câble échec l'ong enda dame imaginons
rien fait pour référent on peut pas
empêcher cavaliers j'ai trois échecs
suivi du matin se foutrait fort il
n'empêche le roi de revenir en fait ce
roi est pris entre à la fois le fou à
gauche et la tour à droite donc il est
coincé
et comme le cavalier peut faire échec on
peut rien faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire si on sur le
football at war donc faire échec ne sert
à rien quoi faire d'autre imaginons
qu'on essaie de sortir le roi de cette
impasse revin et menace kahn a regardé
c'est très jolie cavalière de échec par
plateau world
et que font les blancs on peut envisager
quoi sur fou de 3 ses cavaliers detroit
un pouf l'alternance n'est même pas la
peine donc si on revient et si on va on
peut pas venir ici parce qu'il ya le
cavalier et la dame si on vient ici en
d2 bien c'est matt quasiment tout de
suite par dame eu deux échecs roi c3 il
ya plus de gaz pour le roi il suffit de
faire un échec et mat
mais il suffit de faire car il ya quatre
essais matin c'est très beau et pas de
case ih les prix d'ailleurs à noter il
est pris par le pion des quatre là la
section beckett il a bien besoin que
l'attaqué il manque un coucou à la tuque
les foudres de retard de corse voilà
donc et si revient ici en c'est beau
c'est une belle combinaison s'il vient à
f1 dans ce cas là le mat va aller
extrêmement vite aussi dans me2 mat
la dame est protégé ici par la tour et
c'est matt voyez ça se joue à un coût
passe quand même couperet c'est
l'entretien est donc surtout prend effet
un échec on peut pas prendre avec le roi
aque aux buts
et puis s'en faut prendre un genou qui a
l'air de rien du fait qu'on ait changé
la tour on a une case de fuite pour
laurent noir bien sûr d'un point f1 il
ya quelque chose dans btan c'est que la
dame peut plus venir en schiste comme
tout à l'heure pour venir faire échec à
nantes alors sur dans le premier fin
effectivement on n'a plus d'âme h coc
sinon on n'a pas vu naître le roi
surgelés sont sur la table du fond
d'ailleurs c'est la partie en avoir donc
cornouaille voit que roy prend ne marche
pas donc qui fait dans prend il se dit
mot sinon je m'en sors sauf que touré
fuite
il ya on a le fonds s'inquiète pas de
tourner cette de toute façon dans ses
dépositions donc touré suite attaque la
dame s'est pas garde on va revenir avec
la dame sur une autre position par
exemple ici il vient
1 il aurait pu venir l'ancien sociétaire
et recréer la pseudomonas en fait le
problème n'est pas là le problème est
que dame f4 et c'est le fameux mode du
pouf
du côté du coup le fnsa du côté échec
avec derrière suroît et fin toujours
pareil cas d'allergie trois mots le
regard d'un machin et il faut se mettre
en vis-à-vis
à noter que fou prend 1,5 ne fonctionne
pas parce que le foot blanc qui en d4
protège avec les f2 sur fou prend à
verrouiller à noter que le fou contre la
kz2 effectivement sur flu prendre on a
quand même deux échecs dames deux échecs
on est protégé à la fois par le cavalier
et par la cour est en fuite il faut
venir en h1 et on a le ici le fameux mat
du push couleurs vallée du pouf couloir
exactement le pouls fouloir ici parce
que dans mes fins échec dans prend et
après ici c'est simplement tout reprend
échec et mat
je suis coincé par mes propres pions qui
font le fameux couloir c'est un petit
couloir qui une fois il ya les trois
pions et leurs ouailles la menace et 2
c'est le bas du couloir d'envoyer c'est
demain donc d'un f4
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que la menace
c'est quoi ces dames prend h2 matt
puisque la tour ici protège il reste pas
grand chose
reste qu'un seul coup c'est g3 et là on
se dit c'est pas mal j'ai trois parce
que je peux pas jouer d'un f2 échec il
ya le fou donc est-ce que je suis à
madame et faites vous la main c'est ça
en fait très simplement cavaliers projet
trois ont fait sauter le dernier
défenseur la menace ses cavaliers f2
échec suivi d'un prof de maths que font
les blancs si les blancs jouent le coup
fou prend 1,5
ici simplement jours d'ahmed deux essais
matin puisque le cavalier protège la
case achat qui est la seule case de
fuite voilà on protège la création le
gros ne peut pas bouger donc calé j'ai
trois menaces et le qu'est ce qu'on fait
on peut rien faire alors on va revenir
en avance et mathis y ait en fait
cornouaille abandonne sur ce magnifique
les projets 3 vous voyez comment la
taille il faut être précis parce que à
un couperet c'est les blancs qui gagne
et ça se joue sur le fil du rasoir c'est
souvent le cas des attaques de côté
opposé mais vous avez vu que la taille
du côté dan est pas la même que celle du
côté aura du côté droit c'est matt qui
côté dames séguin un pion le gain
matériel c'est moins bien que le gain du
roi et ça crée des menaces autrement
plus urgentes
alors on va essayer de voir simplement
puisque on a fait tout reprendre
t'aurais fuite en voyant qu'est ce qui
se passe si la dame revient sur sa case
en c1
parce qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure on a
vu de continuer à jouer le coup de main
mesdames c1 ça reviendra à noter que ça
contre lacazette 4 donc la possibilité
de jouer d'un méchoui 4 est pas là et en
plus il ya toujours cette menace
potentielle de venir en 6 avec tout
j'essaie ce l'échec si le fou à les
faire un peu n'importe quoi sans faire
gaffe
donc comment les noirs ici aurait fini
la partie mais fou prend des quatre
échecs alors on peut faire fou prendre
des quatre échecs
cette fois donc le cavalier reprend 1
forcé et maintenant regarder
il ya simplement jour f2 par exemple
c'est le plus simple
tous rêvent 2 donc il ya plus de toute
façon il n'ya plus de menace d' échec
ici de toute façon et tous rêvent de
comment je fais maintenant pour parer la
menace celle d' dans le projet de maths
la question reste entière à vous de
jouer
faites vous la met alors à noter qu on
pourrait te diront oui peut-être échec
parce que si le roi monde je refais
échec et je peux pas aller me cacher
enrichissent puisqu'ils à la dame mais
si je fais les chèques ont regardé la
dame peut prendre simplement donc la
dame est magnifique parce qu'elle
attaque et en plus elle protège la case
s'est vite
alors si les blancs ou rouges et trois
autres possibilités il ya plus mat
simplement damage 3 un joueur 1 h 3 je
contrôle toujours la casse s'est vite
donc l'échec est pas possible je vous
donne une tournette et je menace matella
comment je protège mais je peux pas je
peux pas c'est matt donc abandon voyez
magnifique un très très très belle avec
occasions et rebelles attaquent leur
typique des estoniennes est typique des
joueurs de talent de cette époque qui
avait pour armes face à d4 l'estonienne
et face à leucate la fameuse sicilienne
et c'est hugo reach fait partie des
joueurs avaient fischer qui ont
popularisé ce type de de jeu qui est
beaucoup plus agressif que les partis
qu'on avait dans les années 50 avec
notamment les branches stanley beauté
unique qui était beaucoup plus
positionnelle qui vous est de longue
main d'oeuvre de louvoiement avant que
la situation ne s'éclaircisse et que les
escarmouches tactique finissent par
faire la décision là on a vraiment un
jeu qui est orienté vers l'attaqué un
jeu très tendu voilà très tendu où
chaque coup vise vraiment d'essayer
d'augmenter la pression au maximum
on a vu on n'hésite pas à les prendre
les pions et à prendre des décisions est
bon mais ici c'est les noirs qui sont
passés et puis s'il avait fait une seule
imprécisions s'ils avaient été bloqués
dans leurs attaques si les blancs qu'il
aurait gagné grâce à leurs intérêts
matériels du côté dames magnifique
partie de grigory grand champion il faut
voir les parties de grégory ça fait
partie des des apprentissages
nécessaires à la maîtrise du jeu je
crois que c'est assez clair élus bolivie
tx qui sont et qui son successeur chez
les ch yugo les familles homo qui était
un grand joueur sicilienne aussi donc
merci jérôme de nous avoir accompagnés
sur ce retour historique
c'était un grand plaisir et je vous dis
donc
la prochaine fois promis notre émission
sur les grands champions du jeu d'échecs
dans canal tv au revoir au revoir